Steve Zahn from the nobody BC show the
crossing good to see you what's going on
man how are you how are you oh my god I
was gonna introduce you as a Spence from
All My Children that's how most of us
nice yes
how were you a young girl you did that
or you a kid Spence yeah I was I was you
know you moved to New York you're an
actor okay see you really yeah yeah I
was like yeah I moved from Boston and
came here and those jobs were amazing
because they paid your rent in one shot
it would called under-fives you have
under five lines not over you telling me
that's my whole careers been under five
yeah and you know who else was in there
sure that Parker Posey but Wow the
minute you hit six lines it was like now
that's a different category exactly it
was like now I'm a semi right I never
got above that so I don't even know what
that was I was Parker Posey totally
unnoticed before house of yester all
that stuff Parker and I the first job I
ever did New York was with Park it was
like uh these HBO HBO did these kind of
like family the the
they were like learn a lesson kinda like
an after-school special yeah and I did
one it was like about AIDS in Parker and
I were the the Friends of the stars and
we had like yeah we got in trouble for
laughing I remember and then we got in
trouble on that soap and then we did
suburbia together who is the who of the
stars though do you member who the two
stars rather that you guys were know or
they don't remember but one of the the
guy one like acting competition on TV or
something I just loved it like it was
that show I don't know an acting
competition I don't know
Oscars never they would come on and
there would there wasn't like it was
like it was like American I don't want
for act yeah yeah yeah I probably never
saw it yeah come on somebody help you
know like they would act out scenes and
it was rosy glasses yeah
Star Search
starsurge they do acting from Star
Search what did they do acting things I
remember cigars you monologue they had
like a category an acting category know
that how I don't remember that and I
guess they would throw you a scene and I
just love the idea that like these two
stars are trying to do like this really
serious thing about aids and two new
actors are just sitting there yucking it
up in there jiggling distracting
everyone we got in trouble and we got in
trouble on the soap - for laughing soap
seem like they're hard to shoot because
the amount of you have to do it a day
and it's got it is impossible it is
right it's really yeah those people it's
just about memorization except for the
under-fives I mean it's easy if yeah but
I had one I remember I had a speech once
it was very very difficult cuz I had to
I had to split I was a lifeguard and I
had to split everybody who they were
having an argument I had to split them
into teams for like water volleyball so
I had to go I had a name I had to point
to the person and go like and it wasn't
like Bob and yeah Karen it was like shun
John say and Marlena yeah and I didn't
know who was who was insulting and so
now you have to do I have cue cards and
it was embarrassing they have to wear
stuff read their neck like [ __ ] luck
to fall in the godfathers lines it seems
like a hard way to make a living so
sticking sticking post-its on their
heads with your lines on it that's the
beauty when you can pull that off
yeah that's what Brando would do Hey
headphones guys yeah good I just I know
I know as you do that like at the
beginning you're like not yet and then
you're like you know what I'm just gonna
ride this out I'm crazy that way yeah
you're unpredictable
you might like avignon you regretted you
said not doing doing that my bag sweats
powder that [ __ ] got a powder I've done
that when I was a teenager and it was
not good well Underpants are better yeah
so you turned down Band of Brothers I
don't know if we've talked to you about
that before but you have a big what made
you turn that down I never regret yeah
um even if it was a piece of crap it
would have been the biggest regret I
um we were pregnant at the time and you
know shot in like Ireland it was one of
those things it was sometimes the
logistics involved with with making
something counter your life
yeah you know what you how you want to
live I mean it would have been it would
have been really difficult for me to do
that but you wish you could have because
are you looking at the military me into
that thing and that was phenomenal
why don't you um and you know or it gets
man all these you know and they knew
that I loved it it was very difficult
you were gonna join the Marines but you
didn't yeah
why didn't you as a [ __ ] okay yeah
that's a man I never thought of it yeah
no I
yeah that I thought that was that was a
smart move in high school at that didn't
last long and the guys knew that I was
interested at first you know they
recruit guys and then you come to every
football game yeah my mom was like hey
tell them to go away or they would come
try to get you every just they were just
really like hey we're supportive
whatever we'll come to your play we'll
come to your right football game right
do whatever they can to get a record
really kind of it was really incredible
they would always know like I know
they're good the recruiters are really
good in the military because they can
tell who you are like if you're an
athlete they know how to position that
like whenever in my school the military
recruiters would come in like on career
day they'd always be there and their
opening line for me was like you know we
also have like computer stuff and stuff
like that in the military just knowing
I'm not going out on the on the
battlefield you you have I saw on your
thing that you like goldfish right a
fish right well you knew that we do
animal things on obviously basic
training is that turned everybody off in
the military yeah just is it so
difficult
yeah I mean I don't know I was kind of
into it and then I realized I was into
it for the same reason that I do the job
I do today I was just kind of an
idealist the image of it yeah I just
want to wear the uniform and pretend and
run through the woods and build a fright
you know and throw
apples at cars yeah really I thought
that's kind of hey that sounds great
just do the cool stuff I don't have to
go to math class right right
then I um yeah I remember they were like
hey do you like tanks you like when they
know yeah yeah sign the paper
yeah I didn't do it oh you signed it and
didn't go huh
you saw everyone on all you didn't sorry
okay mom dad I signed up for the
military why would you do that I'm gonna
drive it tank wait what hey it's either
that or the theater right right oh
that's a tank so you ended up going into
theater instead yes and it's a natural
the next step I guess yeah it was there
like yeah that's one of the two they're
very similar
after how did you deal with the with the
lack of manliness that is generally
associated with a is there that's
ridiculous
yeah yeah I never I never had a problem
with that yes Sam even in high school
yeah yeah I mean yeah yeah no I was you
know if you're good at anything
people just respectfully wow you're a
great you know figure skater righty crap
how do you do that right you know so you
were good at acting like from the
beginning yeah yeah it was something
that you know I did well I just never
thought of it as it as it as a job you
know reoffended this Sam called your
profession not masculine a marine I
should radio always the Marines are very
similar right you have to make the call
in an instant am I gonna wear headphones
or am I not gonna wear separately you
don't care about each other what's your
favorite military movie he wants to know
ask it make me nervous
right Robb's over there video my kill
zone yeah tami apocalypse girl ah well
pocalypse now is that really that's not
really a military movie though know what
I mean I mean
Vietnam movie let's be more specific
about it nam full-metal-jacket satin I
love the first 45 minutes but the second
part ah see I love that too I love the
old Marine ah all I've ever asked my
Marines to they obey my orders they are
the others to di oh this is the guy over
in Vietnam oh yeah
Vietnam where they get over there yeah I
mean the guy who's like where's that up
yeah what's that some kind of honey let
me win guys the [ __ ] best I want to
just take a [ __ ] road trip with him
yeah yeah all right Ryan [ __ ] on you no
girl wants to [ __ ] ya never get you laid
remember the old guy from Full Metal
Jacket when they're standing over there
looking at those bodies in a lie pit no
I don't know yeah you've heard that song
these boots are made for walkin on me so
horny Full Metal Jacket Go Go I always I
always tell girls I'm on a date with all
right
70s and 80s movie trivia every time when
you're dating you know girls in their
20s now I love it so alright so not
familiar what do you think why do you
think Apocalypse Now is not a I mean
it's it's you know Vietnam is the
perfect backdrop for that story mm-hmm
you know for that kind of epic journey
story you know down the river yeah you
know just fit and it's brilliant you
know so weird to see Harrison Ford in
that movie - it is it's such a small
part you know who else is in the movie
are lee Ermey I didn't know that yes
who is he play he's a helicopter pilot
when they go into the when they start
ray
you know he's sure companies very
prominent - I asked him about that when
we were I did saving Silverman right and
he was like yeah I was living he was he
told me that he was living in the
Philippines that's really shot it and he
was the Marlboro guy and a lot of ex
vets lived there a lot of Vietnam vets
lived in in and in the Philippines and
he was like the Marlboro Man or
something Wow and they were like hey
there's movies coming and they're
looking for vets
that's amazing be in it he was like
great I did not know he was one of the
[ __ ] helicopter honey either that's
such a beautifully shot scene when
they're all coming in off the water like
that's so crazy music how long did that
take
I mean you and you look at movies like
that and we're so used to seeing you
know effects and special effects
yeah and and and that's all real man
yeah you know real helicopter is really
real synchronicity yeah choreographing
that are you kidding I love and lady
throws the [ __ ] hat in a helicopter
that's perfectly shot up above like yeah
it's great I'm gonna watch that again
just to see him yeah you just don't yet
yeah find the scene so you're a speaking
of wars this show that you're on called
the crossing it was it's going to go on
and the basically the premise is that
you're a sheriff in a small town yeah
and a bunch of bodies get washed up to
shore and when they come back to life
they still come back to life there's
dead bodies but they're alive though
right rhymes like a walking dead thing
they're not so no no no and look I
refrain from using the term time travel
because immediately that puts it to me
that makes it sound bad Yeah right I'm
travel right like it's not like a sci-fi
II no I see I'm not a sci-fi guy you
know I'm a but kind of war like Western
guy and I don't buy like if you say you
have to first believe this world that
we're creating and then there's care
I'm just not got never watched Star Trek
sure no I'm not that this is about today
right small town and these people come
up and I think yeah okay you
time-traveled from your cult and right
you know like the reasonable kind of guy
and then you have to believe it and then
you do believe it and then you try to
figure out what what's going on so how
do you it
I was watching like the trailer for
because it premieres tonight at 10:00 on
ABC but like the whole idea is like how
did they end up getting into the past
and what did they do and one of them
like can jump really high and often but
can't you just ask him like where'd you
come from what did you do yeah and they
tell us oh what do you like no one
believed so that travels the different
time you're on you know obviously it's
not it's not a show where we're you know
we we that's at the end of this all
their time travelers like right away we
know what there's Rio we there's war and
destruction and we left and we found we
know the history we went to a time that
is really peaceful and productive and
and where it's not cloudy all the time
the the writers really did a lot of
research into things they talked to like
all these scientists and NASA on that
like with technology let's say that time
travel was figured out let's say there
was some kind and these guys didn't
laugh they were like look how far in the
future would that be five hundred years
six hundred years and they were like no
this is technology's going so fast it's
like 150 years like genetic Rhian
hansung genetic renouncement or you know
these we feed them and then they they're
like is this real meat like they don't
eat meat anymore it's genetically right
you know there's you know there's all
these things that are being worked on
now right you know so it's there's all
those you know aspects to it that I
think we're really interesting it's it's
it's slow-moving and it's in believable
characters and if I could time-travel I
would do something just worthless to
annoy everybody that would go back like
to last Tuesday and
by a hat that I didn't forget by now I
would tell people that's what I did with
my time travel you look you [ __ ] you
could have done anything to stop Hitler
I learned that by the way one guy go
back and forth one round trip yeah I
left in the cab I'm gonna go back and
tell myself in the past so don't leave
yes don't do the thing you wish to where
you see you late and you tip your cap
you look like an [ __ ] anyway concert
for show it is it is it is it's uh I
don't know I thought it was interesting
and and uh you know yeah you have it so
I did it
is there any intimidation on your part
when the trailers come on and they're
like from the creators of Lost comes
this and you're like oh my god loss was
this huge show do we have this pressure
of be honest to be honest with you I
never watched that show right I've never
seen one you know and I know that sounds
great I just don't I'm not I don't like
watching stories I watch the news right
and watch like you know hey you know
it's a championship game tonight you
know you don't like something that's
episodic oh yeah I have but now that you
can actually watch things binge watch
it's it's a little more interesting much
better it's the less of a commitment you
can just go oh right and that's why I
think audiences are getting really smart
and now networks have to get really
smart with their what they but they put
on right there they're competing against
really good storytelling and it can't
write for the commercial anymore
right what's what's the percentage of
people that are actually sitting down
with popcorn going commercials I have to
pee right how many people for real I
mean even if you're just watching if
you're watching ABC at 10 o'clock it's
not you're still pausing on the DVR
running upstairs exactly having a
sandwich coming back him so so you know
I was like don't don't write for
commercials write a show and then pause
well yeah go to the commercial when you
have chosen Eden come back into the
scene yeah writing for commercials
exactly it that's how shows were
structured it was like he was there was
like an arc
yeah you know and that's
made them kind of seem like the same
show and they all have to kind of be
self-contained because it was this idea
that even though there's an art that
travels through the whole season or
whatever we don't know if they're gonna
watch every episode so we have to have a
nice little ending at the end of the
show which is now it feels more like
they're getting into this better thing
which is a season of TV becomes this
long movie where a story kind of gets
told throughout right
yeah where's character driven yeah and
it's you know and there are plenty of
examples of that working that you would
think you know 20 years ago like no
that's not gonna work yeah and people
people are pretty pretty smart we have
one minute left by the way and I'm
working on a show right now I'm doing a
show um it's political it's about like
the whole US Russia thing and how our
problems are solved for the dance with
the dance with dance the dance off do
you have a name for it now yet no it's
almost dance yeah a street dance like
dancing like yeah yeah yeah just we got
a dancing is smart secret that we
haven't really the Grebe's here is but a
musical yeah yeah yeah a lot of Russians
in America we ran Singh is there like
yeah getting the issues out there right
the issues of the day solved through
dancers dance let's I think a great idea